Fantasy is certain, certainly a very common thing that everyone engages in. And
when I'm talking about fantasy, it doesn't necessarily have to be erotic or
sexual fantasy. a lot of people daydream or fantasize about multiple things
throughout the day. So, maybe the perfect job they want or maybe like a certain
house or maybe the latest, you know, iPhone or whatever the situation may be.
And so, its completely natural that people might fantasize about sex or erotic
touch or just liking someone and being with them. In fact, in some recent
studies 93% of men and 86% of women reported that they do engage in, in
fantasy. It can be really helpful for individuals to be engaging in fan,
fantasy-type thoughts on their own as long as, again, they've got some
cognitive kind of restructuring that they've done. If they have any walls or
blockades around sex or sexuality. so that they aren't kind of beating
themselves up later for fantasizing. So as long as they know that it's okay and
they're comfortable doing that, then it's fine. Couples also can engage in
fantasy together. So they can tell each other their fantasies, tell each other
their desires. And it doesn't necessarily mean that they have to act on those
as a couple or as individuals. Fantasy is, in it's definition, a fantasy. which
often times is things we might not do or maybe that we have done and we're just
thinking about in hindsight. and as long as it's done in a way that is healthy
for the individual, healthy for the couple, then absolutely. It's totally
natural normal healthy and nothing wrong with it.
>> At what age is it possible for people to reach orgazam, men and women?
>> That's a great question. So, I hear this question a lot. you know when, when
can people orgasm, when can they kind of experience sexually, you know,
positive feelings, And so it's really interesting is, there are images of
infants in utero. Particularly male infants or infants with penises we don't
really know their gender yet, but there are images of them in utero touching
their penises, fondling themselves. So one of the things that the techs that
look at ultrasounds in the medical field will tell you is that oftentimes. It's
hard to identify male infants because their hands are usually between their
legs so much in utero that they never actually are able to see the penis. And
so, although we can't be certain because, certainly there is no way to get
inside the mind of an infant or even really ask them any questions. There's
pretty good literature to support that both babies that happen to be male and
babies that happen to be female are experiencing sexual feelings, orgasmic type
feelings when, when their touching their genitalia. Which is a totally natural
normal thing. Even for small infants and toddlers to engage in. now are we
talking about, you know, an orgasm where a male actually like ejaculates. Well,
no, certainly not in infancy. that doesn't happen until males tend to be like
12, 13 years old. But if we're talking about orgasmic feelings, there's,
there's actually, we don't really know exactly when that starts. It's, it's as
young as the person you know, becomes curious about their own body and, and
starts exploring, so